going back to the social media aspect of
the film how much do you feel a pressure
to promote yourself on different
platforms and then how much of your own
need to kind of be true to things it
sounds like you have a real need for
that and that's great that you really
want to stay true to yourself and to the
things that are around you how much of
that plays into what you do on social
media cuz it's a weird thing with it ya
know it is it's really weird and when I
first had moved to LA I had Twitter and
all of that and Lync was very into
Twitter and two weeks ago I did an
interview on a new show called truth and
they asked me to tweet and Isaac I
haven't tweeted in a couple years and
the producer looked and was like you
actually haven't tweeted like in a
couple years and I was like yeah and so
I had to like redo my password and sign
in and like tweet about this show and
now I'm tweeting because I found out my
managers say that booking you don't you
don't book as many jobs if you don't
have that many followers because they
want your fan base to bring in to the
show or film or anything so it puts a
certain pressure on you to be
interesting where I'm at I'm a single
mom and my day is pretty much me and my
son was hanging out and he's one so I
really I'm not that interesting at all
anymore I'm usually just playing with my
son changing diapers and seeing my
friends whenever I can but now I have to
on social media be like oh crap I am
working like I am filming right now I
have to like post and I see things like
I that is that's a weird uh sure to try
to make my life look any type of
fabulous which I don't know I mean I
guess it is fun it's fun
filming it's fun to take pictures and
like I have a terrible memory so I guess
it's good for me to look back at
anything that I posted in the past and
be like oh I forgot all about this and
doing this and doing that so now for me
it's almost like online I'm using it
more of like a diary a public diary
where like my son's first steps are on
it is like first little sentence
I don't know holidays filming all of
that stuff has become public and and
yeah it's it's strange to try to word it
and make it interesting for other people
because of to me it's my entire world so
it's interesting to me but I don't know
how to portray it to others and I hope
I'm doing it in an honest good way and
that people are interested in it
you